jetzt rechnet barack obama knallhart mit
donald trump ab im umkämpften
bundesstaat pennsylvania waren obamas
erste große wahlkampfveranstaltungen für
seinen früheren vize-präsidenten joe
biden der am dritten november gegen
trump antritt unsere demokratie wird
nicht funktionieren wenn die menschen
die uns anführen sollen jeden tag lügen
und sich nur etwas ausdenken wir sind
taub geworden jeden einzelnen tag fakten
prüfer können gar nicht mithalten
der republikaner sei unfähig den job
ernst zu nehmen
er hat kein interesse daran gezeigt
seine arbeit zu erledigen oder jemand
anderem als sich selbst oder seinen
freunden zu helfen oder die
präsidentschaft wie eine reality show zu
behandeln um aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen
mit bezug auf die korona pandemie warf
obama präsident donald trump versagen
vor
dass viele menschenleben gekostet habe
wir haben dem weißen haus ein pandemie
strategie buch hinterlassen dass ihnen
gezeigt hätte wie sie reagieren könnten
bevor das virus unsere küsten erreicht
sie haben es wahrscheinlich benutzt um
irgendwo einen wackeligen stuhl
abzustützen
wir wissen nicht was aus dem strategie
buch geworden ist obama hatte sich nach
dem ausscheiden aus dem amt wie üblich
bei ehemaligen us-präsidenten mit
öffentlicher kritik an seinem nachfolger
zurückgehalten
seine beißende kritik an trump in
philadelphia
pünktlich zum endspurt des wahlkampfes
stellt aber eine deutliche verschärfung
seiner tonlage dar
wir stehen hier in einer der nobelsten
nachbarschaften von washington dc und
hier wohnt ein sehr berühmter anwohner
der ehemalige präsident der vereinigten
staaten barack obama daran vielleicht
auch zu erkennen dass hinter mir ein
polizeiauto steht rund um die uhr
bewacht wer in diese straße hineinfahren
darf natürlich nur die anwohner der
straße aber der berühmteste anwohner
dieser straße der ist heute abend gar
nicht da
denn barack obama gab heute seinen
wahlkampf debüt seinen ersten
persönlichen auftritt in wahlkampf 2020
in pennsylvania ja natürlich unterstützt
er seinen ehemaligen stellvertreter joe
biden bereits seit dessen offizieller
nominierung zum
präsidentschaftskandidaten der
demokraten aber bislang eben in
digitaler form fundraising events oder
auftritte in wahlkampfspots bislang eben
nicht mit einem persönlichen auftritt
und das holte er heute in pennsylvania
bei einem so genannten drive in car
rally nach das sind veranstaltungen die
gerade jetzt während corona sehr beliebt
wurden bei den demokraten weil die
zuschauer nur in ihren autos zugelassen
werden auf große parks vorfahren und
deswegen relativ sicher durchgeführt
werden können ja und so gab es neben
klatschen und rufen für barack obama
heute auch hupkonzerte und dieser trat
auf recht lässig lediglich begleitet in
einem hemd hochgekrempelten ärmeln und
einer maske mit der aufschrift rot und
darum ging es natürlich auch
hauptsächlich in seiner 40-minütigen
rede
er ging ein auf die wunden punkte der
tramp regierung allen voran natürlich
den corona krisen-management er wurde
auch sehr persönlich ging auf den
charakter und das verhalten von
präsident trump 1
aber seine große botschaft war natürlich
geht wählen und diese war vor allem an
die schwarze bevölkerung in pennsylvania
gerichtet knapp zehn prozent der wähler
dort sind schwarz und barack obama ist
nach wie vor ein zugpferd in diesem
staat er selbst hat ihn zweimal gewonnen
ist immer noch unglaublich beliebt bei
den schwarzen die diese wahl mit
entscheiden könnten und pennsylvania ist
in diesem jahr einer der battleground
states einer der wichtigsten und am
härtesten umkämpften staaten dieser wahl
und aktuell führt joe biden zwar in dem
umfragen aber barack obama sagte auch
wir dürfen uns darauf nicht ausruhen wir
dürfen nicht selbstgefällig werden auch
vor vier jahren
hillary clinton führte und wir kennen
alle das ergebnis am ende holte trump
diesen rostgürtel staaten ja auch
genannt wird ein sehr wichtiger staat
bei dem es eben sehr viele wahlmänner zu
gewinnen gibt und deswegen die botschaft
geht alle wählen es ist wichtig jede
stimme zählt was man am ende hörte aus
obamas team ist dass er wohl noch einige
andere auftritte plant also
möglicherweise werden wir ihn in den
nächsten tagen auch noch in anderen
swing states wiedersehen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren